we'll open up uh the subcommittee on HB
1365 in which the subcommittee already
had passed a motion to uh interim study
the bill but there's been a request to
revisit this issue um and since it's
just a subcommittee we're we certainly
can do that so who who is here in the
audience who's here for 1365 please
raise your hand okay is there anyone
here who um thinks the interim study uh
decision
okay okay so the rest of you are here
because you think we should pass this
bill is that correct everybody thinks we
should pass this bill okay so um I'm
willing to revisit this issue on the
grounds that what we do in Commerce is
what we care about is insurance and cost
to
insurance and certainly we don't like to
see any mandated uh plan that would
actually increase costs to people so in
that sense is uh we would pass the bill
with some kind of an amendment that
ensures that um these this does not
increase the cost I had gotten uh an
email
um that uh said a pharmacist may
substitute an interchangeable biological
but not at an increase to cost to the
patient I'm not sure that works
either because that's increased cost to
the insurance compan is what is I mean
cost of the patient versus the cost of
the thing um
from is who what insurance companies do
we have here in the room we have anybody
in
Insurance want to speak for the
insurance
companies
um what do what do you want to
do Mr chairman inter interim
studies okay you're you're in support of
keeping us the interim study I I'm in
support of examining the issue
thoroughly because there's been a lot of
differing opinions on this and there's
been information and and what some might
call misinformation and I think we need
to figure out what the truth is we
certainly don't want to risk increased
costs because prescription providers
pull out of the market because they're
forced to do something that's different
than what their in network prescribers
would have them do or something
different than what the patient would
expect and I know you want to you want
to keep concentrate this on the the the
segments that are specifically chartered
to Commerce which is Insurance correct
um but part of insurance and part of
healthc care costs in general are not
doing things that could
impact onward care in other words if a
25-year-old new grad pharmacist from you
know Mass College of Pharmacy which is a
good school um working at the grocery
store pharmacy decides they want to give
you something different than what your
40 years of experience Dartmouth hemo
oncologist with two fellowships decides
I mean that impacts the care plan and
ultimately the cost of care for that
patient and we should look
into and I'm absolutely willing to work
on it over the summer truly work on it
more than just one meeting in October
look at the definition of
interchangeable and biosimilar we have
two separate things in our country in
Europe interchangeable is a synonym for
biosimilar they don't separately Define
them and this practice does what the
bill asks a different practice occurs
but what the bill asks for in our
country doesn't happen in Europe it
simply doesn't I've been in the med in
this device and diagnostic industry for
20 plus years globally in every
continent is this a conflict no um we're
we're not a Pharma we're not a Pharma at
all we're transplant Diagnostic and uh
Med device there's no conflict at all we
don't do anything with drugs
and thank you I would have disclosed
that had there
been uh we do have experts here and and
but but if the experts are going to talk
about the
biological which is you're talking about
about the biological seminar bi this and
all that stuff again I don't want this
bill in this
committee here it's here it's here and
so therefore right now I want get R of
this bill all all the more reason inter
room study it no right no wrong all the
more reason to pass it
no let the people who really do know
what they're talking about and really
understand this business we really know
we're let decide that this is not a good
answer we've seen emails we've heard
testimony uh ju I have a I got to make a
comment I I think I know where you guys
are all coming from and I'm going to
defend your position okay okay then okay
at this point I I uh you know
I is this is this bill is if it
it would have should have come to us
only as a second Committee in terms of
whether there was a impact for insurance
okay um since I have not heard from any
insurance company saying this is a
problem I've heard no the the only
people who I've technically heard about
negative things about is from a drug
company which obviously or a biological
manufacturer which obviously that's not
a good good example so at this point
interim studying this bill would have
been fine if we could have then vacated
it to another committee to Health and
Human Services but we can't it is stuck
in our committee so I um absolutely
believe that when it comes to this this
issue coming up to this uh U next
September we're not going to get any
farther along than where we are right
now so that let's just send this along
and let the Senate you know decide
whether what your concerns are are
legitimate or not okay Mr chairman we we
never do that we don't just pass bills
because we don't want to look at them we
want to let the Senate do it yes we do
we we do not Advocate our responsibility
on that and there are I think we just
did that with the marijuana bill okay we
just sent him something that we know
pretty well that they're not going to
like well this would be another one and
by the way some of us did look into this
quite a bit hours and hours and hours
and hours I cannot say that I will know
any more today in a month that I know
right now and I'm ready to argue for
this bill on the merits of the facts and
that is all exactly and representative
spear is one of the most long research
researching Representatives I think
we've ever encountered on this committee
and so she should be able to present
that information I should present my
information we should do our
responsibility and frankly it's too much
to deal with today no right we voted 50
bipartisan unanimous to to to recommend
to the full committee that interim stud
is the right way to go and especially
with the piles of information we've
received in the interim that tells us
that interim study is the right motion
Mr chairman you said it yourself okay
the bill is not ready for you finished
are you
done there was something false about
what you just
said the information that we received
I'm sorry I also I do want to say that
you said that Europe is not using bio
simers or hav't regul they've done more
the EU has done more than we have in the
US they're not doing what this bill asks
they're absolutely not they do not
substitute interchangeables for
interchangeables and the word
interchangeable means something
different in the MDR the medical device
device regulations it simply has a
different meaning you might not know if
you're not in the business but I'm in
the business and I'm telling you we've
also heard testimony to that fact
written and oral that interchangeable
and biosimilar are literally synonyms
like chips and in this country they're
not correct that's exactly my point in
Europe they are here they're not tell it
is okay everybody's made a point right
everybody hases anybody feel like
they've not said what they need to say I
just want to say I don't think we're
bright enough to handle this
ouch according to what so I I I have a
couple of things couple of points I want
to make first of all when we had the
last inim study I went along with
everybody else and voted inim study
because at that point we received
information from amen that said it
should have been handled at the federal
level meanwhile I go on the internet and
find out they one of the biggest sellers
of biosimilars in the world so why are
they telling us we can't have
biosimilars but they're selling them
like crazy in the world so I don't trust
anything that they say and I've got
documentation all over the place that
proves that okay so now I say the
information we were given that day was
not complete and so I went back and I
studied it and I studied it as good as
I've studied anything and now we have
some information now the the people that
complained about the only the only
documents we got and complain of this
thing was from the rheumatoid arthritis
folks so I went online and it turns out
the National Institutes of Health did a
study or collected a study in which they
wanted to find out why are they the only
people complaining because the diabetes
people aren't complaining the cancer
people aren't complaining the Crohn's
disease people aren't complaining the MS
people aren't complaining why are they
complaining they're complaining because
the doctors don't know what inter
changeable biosimilars are interchange
which is the only subset of do drugs
we're talking about today the
interchangeable biosimilars are the
drugs that get switching studies they
are so similar that they are almost
direct Replacements they go through
switching studies and the switching
studies are described in this document
then they ask the the people why do you
not like it and the only complaint they
had was because people didn't feel
comfortable with the idea that a
drugstore was adjusting a change however
this bill doesn't say that the drugstore
gets to do that it has to do it with the
patient's knowledge it has to do it with
the patient's knowledge and it has to
send an information piece back to the
doctor so those two things are taken
care of outside of that we haven't heard
anything that says there's a complaint
against this and that's what I have to
say about this right
now okay represent M you have a well the
the fact is we do have biosimilars and
and interchangeables in our state and
they're a good thing and they do help
cut costs what we don't have are free
substitutions by a non-health care
provider right the pharmacist what do
you mean non-health care provider so
it's a pharmacist it's not a prescriber
they are dispensers they are not
prescribers by our statutes a pharmacist
does not prescribe medicine MDS dos NPS
and PAs prescribe medicine in our state
okay right so if anything if you want to
send the second committe
Ed this is again again this is the
reason why that's exactly that's the
reason why this bill needs to get out of
this that's why it should go to interim
study because you're correct it should
have gone to a second committee so back
to the point we have bios symbolis and
interchanges what we don't have is
dispensers non-prescribers of medicine
making a decision that is different than
what the doctor and patient decided
about their complicated hemo oncology
course of treatment willy-nilly deciding
you're going to get a pill and not
that's not what this thing says that is
not what this says so in incorrect this
says that we will allow and will be the
only state in the country to allow it
and we don't like to be outliers and you
know Mr chairman as well as I do we do
not want to be an outlier in this we are
the only state we would be the only
state to allow interchangeable for
interchangeable substitution by a
dispenser and not a prescriber without
consultation it's notification after the
fact you know as well as I do it'll be a
note in the my chart echart system that
some medical assistant we see and that
prescriber will never see it it's not
colum and say what do you think but you
know what is colum and what you think
it's all the time that a cancer patient
spends with their esteemed hemo
oncologist deciding what course of drugs
is the best and I'm telling you I just
went through it I know specifically how
difficult it is to make the decision on
a cocktail of drugs for a hemo oncology
patient right and my point is we nobody
else in the country does it we'd be the
first to do that to to insert the
pharmacist in that and that's says
nothing about the form factor right a
needle that you have to assemble put a
needle on like a Victoza or an OIC
versus a trulicity or a m they're
totally different you're going into
place I don't want to go okay
representative pelli nice of you to come
in uh have uh youve thought about this
issue at all yes yes and my question is
I want to understand the change um in
the role and responsibility of the
pharmacist
so will you know how ex how exactly will
the role of the pharmacist change and
have we really heard from that Community
to see if they're comfortable with
making these decisions yeah we have
somebody the sponsor is a pharmacist
okay I'm sorry I didn't okay or retired
retired you still have your license okay
so you still a license for so but the
role and responsibility of the
pharmacist will be changing is and that
is my understanding it it has the
appearance of that and that was what my
concern you know it has the can I just
like can I run my meeting the way I want
to run it thank you very
much I can see that okay so I understand
that you know the patient can say no I I
want to but the patient will not
understand what a bios I mean I can
guarantee you 99% of patients will
probably not understand the the concept
the consequences or whatever I I
definitely want to make sure that we're
providing the best choices for and the
least expensive choices for the patient
that's not a question I just want to
make sure that the pharmacist has enough
information and they how is their role
and responsibility changing and then if
there's a conflict between what the
pharmacist says and then the doctor
finds out you know the patient is in the
middle and that was just my concern and
and I before I let you speak Gary that
what I would emphasize is is that is the
communication when decision to
change okay my concern is that um I
would certainly hope it does not happen
in a vacuum that the uh pharmacist who I
understand from your college roommate is
incredibly overwhelmed got so much more
going on is not going to spend a lot of
time you know delving into it that there
is communication between the pharmacist
and the physician about before a
biochain and I don't see that in the
bill gear
so come on up turn the mic on please and
and I would like to see active as
opposed to passive communication like to
be outlined procedurally what has to
happen right would I guess the question
is if we required in this that the
pharmacist has to com uh touch it has to
get an okay from the actual physici
before they make this that's not a bad
idea yeah it's it's impractical good
idea we
so in regards to the practice we do that
today with almost all the other brands
and generics on the
market the bill is very emphatic that
you shall inform the patient so the
patient you have to have a conversation
with the patient and go over that with
them what you're trying to
accomplish so therefore it really comes
down to enabling it to happen not
mandating that it happens as far as
prescribing for drugs under a
collaborative agreement like a phys
assistants there are pharmacists that
actually prescribe these drugs unlike
some of these people who have made a
comment saying we don't so when you
think about the amount of time we go to
school and graduate a doctorates degree
and come out of it we are considered
healthc care providers unlike some other
people may want to think um we actually
have an NPI number we build insurance
companies so therefore what I'm trying
to communicate is there are three things
that are important here one
it's enabling it's not mandatory two we
have to
have inform the patient and shall it
doesn't say should it says shall inform
the patient so you have to have a
conversation with the patient about what
you're doing so would you be okay if we
say have to inform the patient and the
prescribing phys it does say that I
don't see a prescribing physician it
does if you go back and look at we it
says within 3 days we have to inform the
that it's on I don't have the bill in
bill that's the after the fact and it
could be a note in the chart within
three business days following the
dispens the dispens which is the same
requirement today of the specific
product provided to the patient
including the name is but communic be
conveyed by making entry yeah but I
don't see this going to the Pharm to the
to the to the prescriber it goes to the
prescription it says to the patient
after listening to on the radio about
how the big screw up of the computer
systems and the shutdown and and how
they're still don't see in here that I I
could see that it's being entered in the
system but I don't see all I'm asking is
that shall inform the patient and the
prescriber correct just simply all I'm
asking is up at the top where shall
shall inform the patient and the
prescriber yeah correct I think it shall
they definitely if you want to amend it
to say that they shall inform the
prescriber as well as the patient I'm
okay with that okay you want to be clear
about that yes but I want to be clear
that at this point in time the way I
read this this all just tells me is that
it's entered into the computer and that
does not mean the physician will have
ever seen it
so practically how would they get
notified if it's if we amend it like
that like you're going to wait until the
doctor calls you back and they're as
busy as the phac the at this point I'm
just saying shall inform the patient and
and the prescriber okay what if the
patient doesn't pick it up usually
somebody else picks up the medicine for
the really sick people and that's where
these drugs are right that's these
biologics and I have absolutely picked
up drugs for my wife and yes I've waved
being t to the information and that and
all that stuff okay but the the key and
I
think presol hit it right on the nail
yes which is that we the patient has no
clue
anyways okay and that we want we want
you're you of course you would but the
rest of us would have no idea okay so we
all I'm asking is is that the physician
is given notification and therefore
Advance I'm not worried about the timing
because we're just worried about them
getting notified okay that that a change
has occurred Mr chairman if I may and
then within 3 days it'll be entered into
the computer system right represent
pcell do you think that's a I would also
like to just look at the my version of
the bill page two line 18 entry into an
electronic record system as described in
this paragraph is presumed to provide
notice to the prescriber so I'd like to
strike that and say the pharmacist shall
communicate
the product to the prescriber using you
know the following devices if that if
that is approprate I think that's we do
that today as far as but I would like it
that take out that that was put in there
from the prior um when we could go from
A to B and a to c this is going from B
to C so I I hear where you're coming
from I totally support it we have to do
that today when you have a flu vaccine
we have to inform the patient as well as
the physician that prescribed it so
please clarify for me so you agree or
disagree that we're going to remove line
18 uh
B on page two I think I would keep it
but I would make it say that they shall
is presumed to provide notice to
prescrib shall they shall we have to
have some
is that's that's that's good but then
you have the word otherwise so I want to
make sure we're taking out otherwise
well this this stuff here is actually in
the current statute now right in terms
of what the bio similar I'm I'm I'm
really scared to go changing that okay
because that's current law so you know I
mean if we're if we're just dealing with
this other issue
um yeah I I hate to change that I I hear
you that the way you read that is says
it doesn't seem correct so but that if
we want to reinforce what is the right
answer for because of what we're talking
about is these um these bios similars we
really want to have in that section you
the stuff that we're adding new we want
to make sure in there that is where the
um the the provider needs to be informed
so represent hun you're talking about
going be clear about the amendment on
line 10 where it says within three
business days following the dispensing
of a biological product the in
pharmacist or pharmacis shall notify the
prescriber be clear that's what they're
doing okay so um so I guess where
where's the heart of this bill the heart
of the heart of what we're
changing is all B to C yeah where is B
to C in here I
think where where is that Lang it's in
I'm I'm looking at the bold face
language bottom page one top of page
line 30 and the top of page two the
provision shall mean that all biological
brought listed by the food
as interchangeable to reference
bilateral product are themselves
interchangeable with each
other that's the Crux of it that that's
states
so but that's also the Crux of
everything we want to do here right so
what I'm I'm I'm I'm without mucking up
the current LA decision yeah without
McKing up the current law if
um the provision shall
mean that all bisted by the food Runners
is
interchangeable products are themselves
interchangeable with each
other and then however however if
if
um no no no however if this is used it
has to you have to inform the prescriber
the prescriber has to approve what about
right underneath it I know you don't
want to change the existing law but um
online three on page two right uh Roman
numeral 4 it says shall inform the
patient can we just add and the
prescriber yeah I I I think that's the
simplest thing to do I think it' be
simple that's logical but then I'm sorry
I just I'm not really I just want to
make sure I understand would it conflict
with Section
six section six is more 10 section six
talks about the timeline and the process
to do it I just want to make sure that
correct
it doesn't I want to make sure there's
not that 3-day loophole if we add and
the um provider on line
four on line four is I think what we're
trying to get to is that the pharmacist
is responsible to inform both the
patient and the prescriber corre section
six talks about how that happens an
interchangeable prodct for the
prescriber correct because shall inform
do there
informing be uh well then it would be
shall inform the patient in the prescrib
prior
to not prior to because that's a
question at that point in time is it's
back to allowing for The Interchange to
happen think of it this way if you walk
into the pharmacy today and you have a
brand name
prescription you have to inform the
patient if you're going to substitute a
generic they have to agree to it if they
don't agree to it yeah but wait a minute
this it's already been filled no before
you fill it right so that's all I want
to add is shall inform the patient and
the prescriber prior to filling the
order there correct but you have to have
a time frame in there if you want to do
it that it's kind quick prior is prior
prior to filling PRI prior don't don't
fill it until
you inform the prescri the prescriber
informing the prescriber is different
than asking for the
authorization be clear about that I I am
absolutely okay with the fact that all
we're doing is informing the prescriber
correct and not asking for approval
because we know that is a delay correct
okay that but that as long as the you
know that the prescriber has been
informed that at that point if the
prescriber has a problem then they will
then they will call up the pharmacist
and say don't do that don't fill that if
I understand it correctly chairman hunt
when I'm filling the
prescription I both have to inform the
patient so the patient has the right to
refuse it correct okay number number two
inform the prescribers so that they're
aware of it correct that's it now the
question I to be careful of is that when
there we do it prior it's prior
somewhere I I believe that that section
six is just the procedurally process of
getting into the computer system a for
you to get paid and B is to get into
their health records cor that's what I I
so so in other words mechanically if I'm
doing something prior to actually giving
to the patient which is dispensing it I
still have an requirement to send a
notification to the prescriber before I
give it to the patient correct because
when we see shall inform the patient I
assume we all assume that the pharmacist
is talking to the patient by phone
either in person or by phone correct
talking to the patient by phone so that
we are assuming that same
methodology what happened with the
prescriber so therefore that that the
pharmacist is calling the the the
physician's
office and saying is I'm I'm letting you
know by Statute that I'm required
letting you know that I am doing an
interchangeable based upon what the
prescription was written but I am doing
this okay as long as it's as long as
we're informing the prescribers because
I don't want to hang up the patient at
the counter and I have to wait for the
doctors on vacation for 7 days to come
back that's not going to help we all
know that's not that I mean we've all
had our prescriptions filled and yes we
you they have a nurse on staff who whose
responsibility is to is to get that okay
so but that what we're trying to do here
is
ensure that no that when something were
to H bad happen or something wrong to
happen or whether the physician knows
there's something different they should
a have written it on the prescription to
begin with
okay so we're not not withstanding that
they have that responsibility if they
think there's something wrong but what
we're doing is just ensuring that that
communication has occurred in terms of
the pharmacist is letting not giving a
verbal notification through that phone
call or talking with that nurse to say
by the way I am using this statute to uh
to change that prescription as long as
we don't get into the the process of how
we inform because it could be a phone
call it could be like with e prescribing
now was something e prescribed we can
send back a note back to the position I
got car G car this is current law
correct right and it's working it's
current law and so as far as we know you
know that that that is acceptable yeah
process let's leave it let's leave it at
that but we're just adding that it's it
doesn't stop with just informing the
patient because we realize the patient
this is going to be way over their head
because it's way over my head okay but
what's really going on here but that
there is a notification system that it
it occurs let alone that within three
days that that physician when he comes
back from their vacation or comes or
finally decides said gee I wonder what
happened to that patient you know
because I got that information they'll
know exactly what happened when they see
that that filing which probably happens
in 24 hours not 3 days probably and what
I would suggest I do like where you're
going I think it has a lot of merage to
it by simply taking line three and
four is when a Pharm is dispensing is
you shall inform the patient and the
prescriber I think it's critical that
the prescriber is aware of it I agre sir
I just I just want to be um now let's go
be realistic so when most patients walk
in and the pharmacist said hey I have an
interchangeable biosimilar that I'm
going to give you instead most patients
will say I have no idea what you mean I
need you need to contact my prescriber
to make sure he's okay with that I mean
that's what's reality think will happen
so I just want to make sure the spirit
of that process is going to be followed
and that the patient understands that
they're this is what is going to happen
and they probably will if it was me I
would say no not until you tell my
prescriber and he says okay and then
we're good and that's your choice we do
that today quite frankly with diabetic
patients all the time as far as the
insulin a brand of insulin we're giving
um there's multiple brands of the same
basic insulin so at that point in time
the patients probably know know more
about their body than anyone else and
what works and what doesn't work and I'm
sure you don't know this but are there
any incidents or um problems that have
been reported because the process was
not followed or something else was
prescribed and the patient had a
unexpected reaction I'm not aware of it
in fact the FDA went through a thorough
review which released in
October um to basically address that
issue and after looking at numerous
studies across multiple disease
States they found no statistical
difference between the two okay and okay
and that basically helped the FDA at
that point in time address the issue
based upon that the FDA is in a process
now formulating guidance to make the
interchangeable biologics the same as
biologics they were doing away with that
ter analogy because it's very confusing
M um and in Japan they've been doing it
for years I'm trying to get to I've not
been aware of any documentation that
this has been a problem and I have a
quick followup is there and is it true
that there is a finite list of these yes
there is it's a finite list you Happ to
know how many there are um I think
represent representative um Leon Leon um
actually sent that yeah list if you look
at finite it's it's finite and it's
growing but just to give you a sense of
the economics of it again we're talking
about trying to save the insurance
company's money as well as the patients
um biologics in Europe are running
between 20 to 25% less than they are
here in this country so there's a huge
amount of money that can be saved by
bringing Market competition to the
market and finding ways to avoid
stifling the competition and the
insurance industry wants to have ways to
reduce cost and the pharmaceutical
it okay so um what we're going to do at
this point this is another amendment so
we're not going to I'm just going to end
this work session and we'll have an
amendment drawn up and uh and then at
that point in time we can discuss
whether we would reconsider our actions
on interim
study Mr chairman if I make one thing
about somebody brought to my attention
with the amendment about um to ensure
the patient
is no what incre increased cost of the
patient what that's already in the it's
actually in that other statute was well
one of the one of the things that
brought to my attention when you folks
look at the amendment if a patient comes
in and they write
for a biologic but they want the brand
name
biologic they insist on it right now the
way the Amendments written I can't do
that because it would be an increased
cost to the patient so i' would like to
modify it where it says the farm shall
not substitute an interchangeable
biological product that result in
increased cost of the patient unless
approved by the patient so you're saying
the current law is a problem because
pass this legislation no current law
does not have
that no the current law does not have
that per say because the current law
says
um a pharmacist may substitute an
interchangeable biological but not at an
increased cost to the patient and that's
what I wanted to modify you're going to
put an amendment through because if the
patient wants to have a higher cost
product I'm prohibited from doing it
even though they want to pay more money
for
it I think the patient have the freedom
of choice that's all so but that's
current law it is I would not like to
modify if you're going to put an
amendment through may want to do it
that's all I'm okay with leaving it the
way it is yes the FDA rules be out when
when will the FDA you mentioned FDA
forming guidance on this when when did
they expect to release that they
released um a letter if you will to the
public back in January I can get that to
you as well they're looking at changing
all the bio similar Logics I mean
labeling requirements so they're doing I
think for the most part investigating
that they don't even have to go through
switching studies that's what the FDA is
looking at which so the FD is looking at
eliminating the need for switching
studies and releasing further guidance
if that's going happen soon shouldn't we
not be the first state to do this we get
that information shouldn't we be ready
for it so when it gets released we can
take advantage of it not delay things
sure yeah and we can do that in interim
study no because if we have there's few
issues here right it's the few different
policy issues we're talking about I'm
all trying to make drugs more affordable
to patients that have been shown to be
safe and not trying to encourage the
industry with stifling competition I'm
trying to find ways to make the drugs
fundamentally more affordable just to
give you an example himera right now is
over $80,000 a year folks $80,000 a year
there's a generic on the market another
one bio similar that is 90 85% less than
that less than $155,000 a year yeah I'm
aware it's an admirable reason to look
into this for sure okay which is why we
pass it great thank you very much one
second okay John one second yeah this
paper that I gave you is an initial
study an initial set of guidance that's
coming out by the
FDA uh regarding insulin and a whole
bunch of other
biosimilars and you can get the details
if you go on to the website you can get
details for each one of those but that's
guidance that's not the law the law
comes out of the state okay so the issue
is these are bi this these are bi bi
similars not interchangeables and our
policy decision here is are we going to
allow interchangeables for
interchangeables RC Cola for Pep against
that of code it's even more
specific I uh I urge you to uh when if
you run for reelection next year put in
legislation to uh unwind or solve this
this nightmare but I'd rather get it
not
for
do
patient
good
okay
so
guys
okay all right so we will have this
time I don't know how many rules we
broke there
okay okay let's talk about living Oregon
donors so what we have in front of us is
um Insurance departments uh my my
request for them
to create some language uh what's looked
around in terms of other states
evidently this is a uh
a movement and many states have been
doing this legislation and concern um
and um it really just comes down to
it's I yeah but I I hear that liver
doesn't really grow at this point but I
guess it I know that there are liver
transplants but but I don't you know so
I don't know how but anyway okay um so
so at this point is that uh one thing I
I do know done a little homework and and
an insurance company if you if you
already have life insurance they can't
renegotiate the terms over over kidney
anyways um because that they they would
be obligated to if they really wanted to
know whether you have given up a kidney
prior I mean I guess this is a good
opportunity to discuss the difference
between between life insurance and
health insurance you know in life
insurance that the pre-existing
conditions are free to negotiate free to
debate and they can they can decide
whether they want to give you insurance
or whatever the premium they're going to
charge you has to be done at the time um
whereas we don't allow
pre-existing limitations on health
insurance so I I think that sometimes
people get concerned and um that life
insurance is a is a free game in terms
of any of those issues are are can be
talked about and negotiated
so um any anybody uh have any questions
and so what we're going to try to do is
is U this is modeled theoretically that
all the other a lot of states are doing
great all right anybody have any
questions uh the problem is uh the
subcommittee okay so I have so we have
pel's here I'm here is
here and Vincent has been
removed
and right this okay Anita is out of the
room but I I
well we also have collabro and Gibb so
we have you two and
then no you can't do I got two
hands
okay okay so let's just have you know
right okay perfect yeah but that's okay
but it's yeah because I assume all right
assume okay so I will make the motion of
ought to pass on the
amendment and
oh I'm sorry didn't I give you
one here passing it around to everybody
sry okay mment number
0885 88 yeah five H yeah H's okay so it
just adds number five John yeah so I
guess that's what we
added is that it just five yeah because
it it says
replacing well this whole thing I'm just
I thought we rewrote the whole paragraph
but how much how much has this been
Rewritten I'm just looking side by side
to see I can't tell yeah why don't you
come up to the microphone and insurance
department
can good morning chairman hunt uh Jason
Dexter New Hampshire insurance
department uh life and health director
we did two things
in the bill one was to add section five
which is ultimately a catchall
anti-discrimination language no state
did the exact same thing um in 2021 en
coil put out a resolution which said
they liked this idea and they gave some
suggestions um and we in the spirit of
that so that was the one thing we did
the other thing we did is added
disability income Protection cover
which is again when we scanned other
states more often than not they had
disability insurance protection coverage
as well the end coil resolution
reference disability insurance so
there's three sections where we just
tacked on that language so it's really
only one change but it happens in three
places those are the two
things
okay
is the effective date
okay yeah that what they're doing here
fine okay we have motion that's been
made in second uh any discussion on the
ought to pass on the Amendments any none
all those in favor please raise your
five yeah but
he I know but Nita Nita is around so
it's fine it's I know it's five zip five
zip it's
fine a replacement is when here the
person's not here at all but Nita is not
far away and I would not have taken the
vote unless need you know if there was a
problem I wouldn't have done it okay uh
the motion is not to pass as amended any
discussion seeing none all those in
favor please raise your hand 1 2 3 four
five five
liquor
direction
got
okay we let's get
started and first up is uh
10:18
you have you have you passed out 1018
yet no sorry how about which one do you
1540 which one of you you've done 1540
so we'll
just
okay you got
it yeah
108 oh I I don't I don't seem to have it
in front of
me so if you have another one for me
that oh okay there we go
uh okay so uh everybody in the audience
is who car about 1018 has got a copy I
hope does anybody have any problems with
the way 1018 is
written okay except we do have a
problem things are never perfect so the
one is this my y okay the one change uh
that we're going to have to do before we
uh take this up is on page two line a
and um where it says no
Z's um that's supposed to be that level
that that was it no level of Expos yeah
no level the Z is supposed to be level
right where did everybody go
okay okay that's it's the word is
level and that no level of exposure to
safe okay so unfortunately because we
will have to have this done again um but
that's where we'll be at with this bill
all
right it's
two it's still hanging out
there okay so we need another amendment
so we need another
amendment okay next up
have I don't have 1076 in front of me do
you guys did everybody does somebody
have 107 no they okay let's just move on
yeah but no that's the original we're
talking about the 1076 have an amendment
right no the 107 you have a 1076
so
came
oh that's not the
that's oh several that's several
amendments okay so what we have in front
of us is this is just an added length
bill
and
so someone from the L Comm commission
just to uh remind us with this amendment
this thank you chairman yep in committee
members this amendment is just changing
this uh was presented before the
original bill is allowing uh the beever
uh the wine
manufacturers um in the liquor
manufacturers or the wine manufacturers
to have their uh one entitled on
premises license either on the premises
of the um
manufacturing facility or their retail
outlet this is allowing the same thing
for the beverage manufacturers right in
the word in the original Amendment with
May on line 12 the on- premise license
it used to say may either beond and now
it says shall that was the
change we love the May to shall
correct okay any
questions
okay so who do we have here
for liquor is
we
hello so we chairman hunt yeah I think
they also didn't you also change the
manufacturers that's correct the
original bill was for the wine
manufacturers this
amendment authorizes the beverage
yeah
okay all right
um okay so we have burs can't be
you right but we're all going to be
unanimous so we're okay all right so
pusk Walsh hunt post Sullivan
buo and Vincent is suan no Vincent's not
on this one okay so they got Sullivan
yeah suiv okay so
um uh I'll move the amendment number 095
o second and you second it I'll second
okay okay any discussion on the
amendment see none all those in favor
please say
I two three four five right one two
three four five six no no well me six is
it
okay and then um all those in favor um
not to pass as amended any discussion
zip
okay
okay holy moly look how big this bill
has
gotten it's very ti so much so much for
housekeeping huh yeah it's very tight
knuckle
got we are missing two paragraphs out of
this uh Amendment oh okay I just
reviewed it this morning just received
it this morning but we are missing two
paragraphs on page four line six Roman
numeral
7 that paragraph
should be found in the
beverage tenant option and the liquor
tenant
option
okay all right well then we'll wait to
have that Amendment drawn up so would
you make
you you got okay
Amendment
okay moving right
along next up
is uh
uh 13
yes
okay 1380 uh the amendment we uh go from
the original Bill introduced had 5,000
this is bringing down to 25 which is the
current statute and what a uh a brew pub
is allowed to produce in general so it
consistent anybody have a problem with
this
amendment speak now or forever more hold
your
piece
file
afternoon no
paper don't you just use the back side
of the uh Amendment you have a copy of
it
25 is the amendment
that's okay all right so I'll make a
motion about to pass on the amendment
and you'll second I'll second and it's
o72 0872 h
right
MH any discussion seeing
none all those in favor raise your
zip okay um I'll make the motion about
to pass as amended
seconded represent buo and Scott you
want to have your
last tell us why we shouldn't pass this
bill as
amended
to be sure that microphone's on uh this
is with the Distributors Association and
and again um I appreciate the fact that
the bill was amended it doesn't change
our primary concern with the bill this
is not about brew pubs or distribution
this is about cross tier ownership and
prohibited interests and one RSA 17911
in the state and chapter 27 of the
federal alcohol act um there's a reason
that the Liquor Commission denied the
application for a brew pub initially and
that was because it's illegal um both at
the state and the federal level the Nano
Brewer was a a loophole that was
intended to provide an option for the ly
in
question and uh
apparently that wasn't good enough so
here we are with the legislation so we
continue to oppose it on on the Merit
that it does not help competition it
does not help small businesses it's bad
for the industry in general and it sets
a terrible precedent moving forward so
um you've heard our arguments before
I'll keep it short and just wanted to go
on the record and say that we oppose it
um and we think that this is something
that's very dangerous for the industry
and for small businesses in New
Hampshire great thank you thank you is
there anybody else who would like to
amended
okay you see
you okay so the motion is ought to pass
as amended all those in favor say I one
right
okay
okay so Jared why don't you tell us what
this amendment says and
does yeah turn your mic on turn your mic
on please everybody should have it in
front of them does anybody in the
audience not have it no I mean I don't
it's pretty it's pretty minor um
basically the original Bill had a bunch
of different categories of food so there
was like grilled meats and soups and
salads and all these other things pizzas
stuff like that we just took out all of
that to try to explain what food is and
what is counted as food and just said a
full course meal would be a diversified
selection of food I think that's that's
actually timely what I wanted to do
originally but I thought that it needed
to be defined and so I was actually glad
when liquor suggested we just take out
all that other stuff and then the old
bill will uh cut the 20 guests
um uh 20 20 guest requirement down um I
think it was 10 and so here we just
added language unless granted by The
Liquor Commission so they can kind of go
in and and still have the ability to
enforce their concerns which is I guess
a bar opening up and then uh meal shall
be readily available and then we struck
out all that other language just above
it
and so by striking that out um I just
spoke with Danielle and that's going to
cause a reopening of how they Define
some of that stuff which I think will
accomplish the goals that I aim which
aim to achieve which is to make it a
little bit more flexible for restaurant
owners
to have some prepared foods that aren't
necessarily cooked or chopped up in the
kitchen but because maybe they don't
have the space but they can get it from
somewhere else but it's still restaurant
quality food and that will give them the
flexibility to do that because it's
going to open up the rules associated
with it and then U meal shall be readily
served to the table so
um that that obviously needs to be
required otherwise it's not really a
restaurant
so so yeah anyways I don't think it's
particularly controversial I actually
like that this amendment did more uh
towards accomplishing my goals so so
you're happy I'm happy
yeah uh Danielle you
mine
good morning so are we now uh is the
rest of the story going to be in rules
in terms of what the meals are and what
the rules of it y this will um the
Diversified selection of food has been a
standard that we've always looked at
when looking at the menu um these
definitions are hard to look at in a
bubble because it's the totality of the
entire license there's several other
paragraphs that involve the food and the
requirements of the restaurant so
isolated it looks um like we're
eliminating some stuff but it really is
the totality of the business plan and
the establishment coming forward that we
look at each individual definition the
license requirements so um this will
cause some rule changes or some rules to
be reopened and looked at which is what
um representative San was talking about
so we can we can Define this more if we
need to within rule but I think this was
a good compromise it accomplished a
little bit what he wanted to accomplish
and were able to um still look at the
totality of the business plan and the
circumstances for the licenses all right
great
M
okay anybody else in the room who wants
to weigh in speak now or forever more
s
but
you you have a bunch of them over there
hoarding oh that's it that's it yeah no
I have
it I just wonder what happened to the
pile because we thought they were all
at I give you a chance to read it before
action
look
okay
right so I assume this some of the stuff
we Crossing out it's going to show up in
rules
or
right I was amazed
I past couple years I a lot of of movies
about restaurants and the reality is
that meals are all pre prepared and and
in these special drawers that they pull
out and voila there there's the meals so
correct and that's that's specifically
one of the rules that this will cause to
be reopened and looked at the rules that
say that meals can't be leased or
concessioned out um I think it's vague
in nature anyways in terms of what that
exactly means um so in discussions with
representative Sullivan I think that's a
rule that needs to be cleaned up anyways
um and this this would cause that to be
to be reopened and looked at great
good okay so everybody's
okay all right so representative
Sullivan seconded by
0939 any discussion on the
motion all right seeing none all those
in favor say I all right one two three
zip okay representative s second
representative hunt moves ought to pass
as
amended any discussion seeing none all
zip
perfect
all right and last but not
least
1591 okay I assume the amendment's been
happy everybody happy except from that
guy and what
Jersey
1591 and again this is uh this is just
adding
um but replacing section 10 so just one
section of the bill is being being
move second second
0840 seeing none
all those in favor say
I 2 3 four five six seven all opposed
seven
zip so I will move a to pass as
amended seconded by representative
burough any discussion on the
motion see none all those in favor
please raise your hand 2 3 four five six
it and we'll meet back here at
much
for
okay we get
God guess who's spor okay
John all right um so many transmitters
uh if you might recall in their hearing
uh an issue came up uh comparing the the
big guys versus the little guys and the
local guys and uh I'm sitting over here
working out a potential
solution um so at this point we don't
have we don't have an amendment yet and
uh so we'll move this off till next week
um
resolution and what what we're trying to
do is figure out how to carve out the
the little the little ones from the big
guys and um and what we're looking at
right at the mount is these uh stored
value
cards and that the little guy don't do
that and and therefore we would exempt
them what stored value a stored value
card is that you're going to get your
paycheck on a prepaid like a credit card
oh okay right I got it
right yeah when this is when cash isn't
around
anymore um all I know was that that when
I got rid of my Direct
TV and they said we're going to give you
a you know a rebate and and I was
expecting it one of those debit Master
cards and no they it was some some bank
and they wanted to sign me up to a bank
and they wanted me to you know it would
be a prepaid debit card that they were
hoping that I was going to reload it
with my paycheck or
something not that my paycheck will go
very far but so um you paycheck from
here yeah well it's it's my only
employer
so so that that didn't go very far okay
so we'll move on to next one 1444
ahead we had some exchanges about uh the
term proprietary uh cryptocurrency on on
1241 yeah um really yeah
um I I think I just like to hear the
justification for adding the word
proprietary to that
language
correspondence
right yeah so in uh in the
bill there there it's uh page 24 line
there and I'm looking I'm looking at an
email from February
13th
okay uh
24 you could you say the page again sure
okay good afternoon um
for the record I'm Bob lamber from the
banking Department I it was a little
tricky to hear but my understanding is
the question about proprietary
cryptocurrency is that where that came
from in the uh so here's the email that
I have it says the language here was
added to try to address the Department's
concern that if and when a business that
engages in such
inflation collapses consumers holding
such tokens may be left without recourse
the proposed language was added by the
department to address this concern
however the the department so to
fine-tuning a language or further
defining proprietary cryptocurrency to
accomplish the goals of protecting
consumers yep that's um that's just
right the the what the department has
seen over the past year or two
specifically relating to the larger uh
crypto companies um the most not notable
example would be um
FTX is Bad actors will use bad actor
companies or entities may use uh
cryptocurrency or tokens that they
themselves create and issue and inflate
the value of those so that their balance
sheet
looks uh better than it really is and so
when these
companies um go under consumers are then
left with little to no recourse in terms
of recovering funds so this language
this is something the department added
uh to try and address that so that they
can't use that inflated value to uh
increase the balance sheet um it is a
sort of a a working term proprietary
cryptocurrency if if the committee
thinks that it could be uh improved upon
uh I think the department's open to that
um but that's sort of the justification
for adding it in there okay so I just
have a couple questions about about that
so in that sentence the word proprietary
procceed s cryptocurrency and this is
comma non-f fundable tokens Toma comma
other digital assets does the word
proprietary apply to all three
categories or not that that is the idea
yeah okay and then just about every
blockchain system has a native token
that incentivizes the the blockchain
itself so would that be considered a
proprietary cryptocurrency if let's say
someone created you know there's
hundreds of these things um um would
that exclude every native token of a new
blockchain um from the balance sheet
when in fact they could have a real
market
value I just want to be careful we're
not excluding legitimate Innovation from
Bad actors like FTX which was I think
they were headquartered in the Bahamas
and outside of the US regulatory system
anyway so FDX was licensed by us however
as a m transmitter um for that portion
of their business where they were doing
fat to crypto money transmission
um so I think what we're struggling with
is the definition of proprietary what
this is meant to prevent is like a money
transmission company um creating its own
token not necessarily using other
people's right um so maybe we could I
don't know if proprietary is defined in
here but perhaps we could Define the
word proprietary to to make sure it's
narrow to that those circumstances does
that seem reasonable yeah thats yeah
would that help um solve your it's a
legitimate concern right so I could
create I could create a token I could
sell it to someone I could create a
billion tokens sell it to someone for a
dollar and all of a sudden that token
has a market cap of a billion dollars
right like and if I have the rest of the
tokens on my balance sheet I could I
could claim that that's worth a lot of
money when in fact it's it's vaporware
right but then on the other hand there
are like well established sure and to
get from startup phase to the well
established phase we want to make sure
we're not uh blocking a legitimate path
to you know sure see what I mean we
could talk more about it yeah we can
talk more about it I think we could
probably solve it with a definition of
proprietary that like narrowly ta tailor
what we mean by proprietary to a very
specific set of circumstances um that
would alleviate your
concerns we're already doing an
amendment because your your proprietary
is that it it was theirs yeah it's the
comp the money transmitter in questions
right that's not and now we're talking
about is that it really does have
underlying value potentially it wouldn't
necessarily the proprietary could have
underlying value it's it is is how do
you how do you measure the value how do
you know right there's no Stock Exchange
there's
no way to to reference whether that
particular yeah has value map out the
difference use cases that are out there
in the in the wild and see which ones so
lots of exchanges issue their own tokens
like binance has its own token right uh
you know there's lots of them that issue
it and they use it to incentivize
certain Behavior what what FTX was doing
was lending based on the value of that
token sort of creating like a Ponzi
scheme right and that's books yeah we
don't want them inflating their own
books artificially saying we have this
token that's what's on our balance sheet
and it's worth a billion dollars what
it's really worth you know whatever um
so my only concern is that we don't
block legitimate Innovation right sure
right but I'm but I'm intrigued because
it it's the devil's in the details it's
the words it's like you know documented
value or proven value or you know again
it's not proprietary it's it's that you
can had evidentiary accountant appr it
evaluation value third party third party
evaluation of the value you I mean I
mean yeah that's um Direction so it has
to be some way it's documented or Prov
proven or independent auditor
independently a independently approved I
think the concern is even more specific
for us it's that they have their own
cryptocurrency and they're using it on
their own books to inflate the value of
their business whereas I think we don't
want to stifle them
from perhaps investing in other forms of
cryptocurrency that are on the market
and valued so but that wouldn't be
proprietary that was there that's an
investment and that's a a balance sheet
item but at the end of the day the only
thing you got is the the
auditor is going to audit the value is
going to be look at the books and it has
to be on an audited financial statement
has to be an independent audited
financial statement are you following
along with this I'm trying to look at my
money transmitter would that be the way
to it has to be has to be documented on
an audited
statement yeah so the the financial
statements are audited as part of this
um license so it had to be by certified
accountant auditing yeah let us think
about it I I I think I understand that
sounds like a good way to do I just
didn't want to leave it with that's you
know think of it I want to get a little
more we've already been in touch with
representative am and preliminarily on
this issue so I think with a little
further discussion we could like figure
it out narrow it down your concern is
legitimate absolutely um yeah but the
word proprietary was intentionally added
and there's no real definition to it so
yeah yeah yeah proprietary was just
meant that the company made it
themselves and they invented their own
value right that's what that's that's
what I you know so you could you could
go into definitions and and say what
proprietary meant and then and clarify
it it's not proprietary to somebody else
proprietary could mean we're saying that
it's unaudited and has has it
supposition rather than really
yeah some third party auditor has
approved that this value is really there
let me let me think about that a little
bit more and we'll work on it okay all
right you still have a question Chris
yeah
just um this is part of the issue I have
with uh if you go and look up
definitions of crypto and youd ask the
Federal Reserve what it is and they'll
say it's it's currency and then you go
to the SEC and they say it's a
commodity and then you go to somebody
else and who says it's
currency nobody res I I looked it up
they couldn't have said it's currency
money it's money they use it as currency
when when when the bank went down in
California they bailed
out uh the uh people that owned their
crypto that were Bank in the bank okay
so I don't know if that's supposed to be
gold or met or maybe it's something like
a commodity the SEC said commodity okay
well I you know so I that's an
interesting commodity they had in those
Banks because it was hundreds of
thousands of millions of dollars of I
think it was paper probably or digital
but the point I'm trying to make is that
this was presented to me as
legislation that was uh specifically uh
you know trying to make a distinction
between the big guys and the small guys
when it comes to money transmitting
that's that's the way I look that was a
small part of issue of this legislation
well I I thought this issue is about how
we regulate and audit uh people who are
in the business of transmitting money
okay the first the first opening
statements here were about the
distinction between the large guys and
and the smaller transmitters that was
what was discussed right off the that
would have been the Peter right Peter so
anyway that was his little issue but but
but the thing is my point is that we
have um have had a ton of
cryptocurrency related
legislation that I think a lot of it is
not anywhere
near uh defined well thank you you know
I mean Trump said you know this property
was worth $2
billion right now you're going off on
the tent well okay the tangent is and
and that's that's what you're talking
about she's the the commissioner is
saying I don't have uh a tool uh in
order to uh functionally tell you what
uh no she's saying is that we all agree
is that we want to make sure we do have
an independent audit value that is not
something that you just say you know be
like Trump and just wing it and say this
is what he thinks it's really worth okay
I want I I my question is can you give
me an example of a specific commodity or
currency or whatever the hell crypto is
and and and and value it so in other
words somebody comes in and okay well I
can give you here's what I'm saying
right now I know what Bitcoin is because
I just saw what happened in the last two
days with Bitcoin okay okay but that's a
third part that the third party is the
free market that is valuing with that
bitcoin's value is okay and it's on the
exchange so you can you know buy and
sell the exchange that's a commodity
okay that's like stock okay you know
we're talking about here is if someone
is issuing a Bitcoin and giving it to
employees or giving it to somebody and
saying this is what it's
worth but that it really didn't had any
underlying transactional value I
understand that that's casino chips so
the thing is um if you if you if the
banking department is is a little
confused or not quite sure of how to
define uh this no we all know what we're
trying to get at these are money Transit
we all know what we want to label it we
just got to figure out what is the right
word so are we transmitting money or are
we transporting coal this is someone's
value that they put on their portfolio
their stock they they're account in
dollars or in crypto in the end of the
day it's being translated to dollars
because that's the way when you file
your tax return when you file your
annual report everything is in dollars
so the issue was when they put that
number I mean here's the classic example
is inventory okay and you are what are
you going to value your inventory at are
you going to value at what you actually
paid for it or are you going to valuate
what it's going to what it would be
worth when you sell it okay and so
theoretically you have to is what that's
the point the inventory in this case
yeah is the
coin but and so therefore somebody would
put on his books and say oh yeah this is
worth
$100,000 but it really wasn't worth
$100,000 has no value $100,000 there's
no there's no way to claim it back and
say that com it's going to give you
$100,000 for that value of what's there
I'm I'm stumbling over the phrase money
transmitter and the fact the money
transmitter is the category in which we
as as legislature have accounted to the
the banking department and uh one of
their activities that they regulate is
money
transmitters and so therefore case one
of the things we care about those money
transits is what is their balance sheet
looks like
okay and the balance sheet what we're
worried about here is is somebody's
making up bake numbers on their balance
sheet yeah I consider crypto all fake
but the but the thing of the matter is
they are they are they are able to right
Chris we got a lot to go here today can
I just say one General go ahead so in
2017 uh we Exempted virtual currency
from the money transmitter laws 399 G
that came through this committee and
went to a commission with appointees by
the governor and then a bill came
through and the governor signed it in
2017 that specifically Exempted roal
currency this is a rewrite of that
entire statute based on model law
correct and we're trying to preserve
that same advantage that we had
established in 2017 and not slide
backwards on it that's that's really
that is absolutely correct okay all
right moving on to
1441 all right relative to local
regulation of digital money
so the amendment Keith that you had it's
being printed yeah so your amendment is
about
um it's I spent it out last night right
but in terms of not with understanding
that it it say about no one can ra you
know
legislatively uh regulated but that if
someone were to they would have to say
notwithstanding this law right if we
were to pass it so the first question is
that is this is this prophylactic
legislation that we're we're saying is
no no one can regulate it when nobody
has done it yet you're keep closing the
barn door before the horse is
out is that what what you're going with
it it it establishes
ownership uh and it's it's uh it would
coincide with uccc article 12 that we
just passed it has to do with self-
custody and it would have the state uh
the state would recognize that self-
custody is is ownership of
property and the original Bill had to do
with Mining and local noise ordinances
right right because our state energy
costs are so high nobody's doing mining
in New Hampshire it would be crazy so
that bill that bill is very prophylactic
replace this would replace that and and
refocus it on the fact so like if you
have cash under your mattress you own
that cash right that's self- custody you
can do the same thing with digital
assets and and correct my proposed
amendment and it's just for discussion
I'm not married to it the sponsor of the
original bill is on board uh other
states are going in that direction it
could be something that we that we do
for this bill did I is this the one I
sent you what did I send you did you had
another amendment on something
else yeah and that one's like that's the
next bill and that's even more farfield
we'll get to it okay that's the
final it should be coming down from the
fourth floor um I think Carri was going
to go get
it question yes I sent it to the
committee last
night
so this is just a question right because
I've never seen this before and just now
uh to be able to use these Assets in
payment for for something like if I
wanted to buy a house and I and somebody
was willing to take Bitcoin to the house
I should be able to do that and actually
I should be able to do that anyway way
right Keith Keith Murphy you can get a
drink I'm
sorry Murphy's bar you can be well
that's that's the question that I'm
asking we're not forcing anybody to take
it no it's just that the state wouldn't
the state would respect self- custody of
digital assets and that's what the gist
of the B and we're not asking the state
we're not asking the state that they
have to take it in payment for any weird
thing okay that's fine then no we
learned that lesson already yeah so okay
all right so we let's wait till that
Amendment comes down okay so now we'll
move on to Innovative Financial this is
sween's Bill right
okay I have a lot of comments on this
one we're now on 1507 because we're GNA
we're wait till 1444 the amendment comes
down I have this one coming down too but
this is up to you whatever you want to
do we could just skip it if you want
well I I did send this to the the
commissioner and you have any comments
about it great come on come on up and
tell us
what could I just interject before you
start the the language and the committee
hasn't seen this language yet so it'll
be but it's it's almost word for word
what's already Statute in Connecticut
right so whether it fits our statutes or
not that's a different question but yeah
right I just understand what's a bank
that doesn't loan money what's the
purpose of a bank if you don't Lo money
payment processor okay is it a payment
processor
and so I guess my so I obviously got
this at a a.m. this morning I sent it to
my team to look at we did some
preliminary spitballing but I H I would
need some more time with it um first my
first thought was which is I think what
I said I think this was a bill that you
worked on maybe before the legislative
cycle started and then you ended up not
doing it um but my first kind of thought
was I think what's being described could
potentially fit under our trust Charter
or it could depending on how they set it
up or it could fit as a money
transmitter so I don't think but again
I'm not really clear on exactly what
we're trying to capture but if it's a
payment
processor those sometimes are money
transmitters um if it's somebody who is
um we've had companies approach us who
are essentially money transmitters for
businessto business money transmission
and they keep all of those assets that
they're transmitting in custody accounts
that's a trust company so I I strongly
suspect that this type of entity um
without knowing more details could fit
under one of our current regimes and you
1507 a lot
question
so and
I'm so we're looking at
um
this's and let's do this soal
Innovative do you by any chance have a
um you have an extra one no I think I
got 10 printed you can have
mine
sand sand this would be in L of the
sandbox in yeah it would be like
you um I called it not non- lending
payment
bank I have a question
do is not this legislation based on
legislation in another state or other
states if I recall non- lending payment
bank or the Innovative sandbox this the
sandbox the both both are in other
states I'm sorry both are in both are in
one's AR okay one is in many other so
the sandbox concept has been done in
several other states with varying
degrees of activity and success that's
what the public hearing what we provide
testimony about the the the item that I
believe is circulating is something
Sandbox it's yeah it's representative
Ammon has submitted it so this would be
something that would come out of the box
this would be like yeah like something
that could a niche uh Charter type that
could be in the sandbox so this is like
very
specific so so question are are we
eliminating the sandbox and then just
going we're just talking we're just
talking okay so um why don't we go back
to why we get more copies of this
language why don't we get back back to
the sandbox so you might want to stay
there right because you have strong
opinions about The Sandbox yeah I can I
can rehash any of the I talked about in
the public hearing if you'd like yeah
why well just tell us whether you love
it or hate
it um I'm not wild about it um but I
could the bill as proposed would take a
lot of work to create a Sandbox that I
think would work the primary issue is we
did not get a fiscal note and if you
wanted the sandbox set up the way it is
I think I said I would need three at
least three maybe four staff members out
of the gate to set it up an attorney an
investigator and an administrator that
was pretty killer that's pretty killer
yeah and then I also like think about
the fun the practicality of a Sandbox um
generally um from what I understand for
financial services sandbox there's lots
of different
sandboxes um but for a financial
services sandbox generally people are
hesitant to enter the sandbox because
any application they submit to be part
of the sandbox would become public so
their um Innovative Financial product
much for being a secret corate secret
right exactly I think some of the things
that were cited in earlier um hearings
or in other sandboxes were things that
were not so much financial sector
related I mean maybe there was a
regulatory component to them but it was
more outside of my purview um so I'm not
sure there's been a lot of success of
sandboxes for financial sector
additionally there was a slew of other
issues with the bill as it was drafted
um for example um entities subject to
the banking Department's uh jurisdiction
are exempt from the consumer protection
act because we can get restitution for
consumers it wasn't really clear if
somebody who was in the sandbox would be
in that position or not um I had some
concerns about how it was drafted with
regard to Consumer harm while somebody
was operating in a
sandbox um there were just a lot of
little needly things like that that
would need to be um really carefully
looked at um before it could go forward
in my opinion so and you said successes
so have some states had some success
with this or were you just
being I I'm only really aware of the
financial services one and I couldn't
find a really great example where they
were like this financial services
product came out of a Sandbox I couldn't
find that there were some things that
came out of sandbox I think one was like
kind of like a zip car and I was like
that's not under my reg jurisdiction so
I don't know
um yeah pass it around to anybody wants
it yeah I got it I got it yes carage so
what I did was I looked at of course in
that way that I have I looked at every
single state to find out which states
had this and what successes and who was
in the sandbox and whoever came out of
it and what laws came out of it every
them in fact there was only one
financial success and then the sandbox
got shut down and that was Hawaii they
were the only ones that had an actual
Financial
sandbox they shut down and their
Innovative their Innovation out of it
was at one time they had 12 companies
the results of the sandbox work in the
area is that Hawaii will not apply the
state's money transmitters act to
cryptocurrency
activities been there done that so and
that is literally the only fin anal
sandbox that I found in in the 12 or 14
states that I looked at and that's all
there is there's ones on nursing there's
one on mining there's one on other
things but that's it so in your search
engine you used the term sandbox uh that
was one of them but I also used final
Financial I used regulatory I
used regulatory sandbox okay they're
usually called sand sandboxes is a good
a good guess that's where I would start
too although I would what I did find
that was urban urban what I did find no
that not usually I did find one thing
that made me a little
nervous
cryptocurrency Publications were adver
advocating the use of sandboxes as a way
to get around State legislation but
nobody was picking them up on
it oh it's the web page he saw so you
know that's about the only thing I saw
with with respect to anything financial
and that's it
okay1
who oh okay 12:41 okay
um okay
so where where are we now we're uh back
amendment can I speak yeah I don't mean
to confuse the issue here with we had a
conversation at T andies we were talking
about this bill right um and and I
mentioned that I almost filed this bill
but I pulled it at the last minute
because I didn't know I thought it would
be too much right um the the issue is
State chartered banks that are
non-lending that would like to get a uh
an account with the Federal Reserve a
master account with the Federal Reserve
and there's currently a lawsuit with
custodia bank out of Wyoming uh that
they're a state Chartered bank and the
FED is refusing to give them a master
account because they're not FDI FDIC
insured and they don't need to be
because they don't lend they're more of
a payment processor or custodian of of
assets they're not doing fractional
Reserve Banking and so that lawsuit is
scheduled to be settled later this month
or potentially April uh by a panel of
Judges if it goes the way of custodia
bank it's going to open up uh
potentially a new you know in in the
financial services space a new uh demand
demand for that type of um Charter and
the states that have it on the books are
where those institutions are going to go
Connecticut has it on the books um I
think Maine and Vermont also have have
it on the books similarly but this
language is lifted right from
Connecticut statutes and it gives the
banking commissioner the authority to
approve or or not approve based on uh
certain you know parameters in the bill
I'm just throwing it out there for
conversation maybe it's you know maybe
it's something we look at later but
um you know it is sort of like a an
issue in the fintech space that may be
resolved federally very soon in State's
favor and we know we want to preserve
State sovereignty in chartering Banks
and this would be so if it resolves in
custodia favor and custodia is indeed
only doing custody work which is not
totally clear to me because I went on
their website and they were advertising
that they hold people's deposits which
is a whole different animal um in my
opinion if you have an entity that's
holding people's money I'm a I believe
that we need FDIC insurance for that
because custodia seems and now I'm not
an expert on custodia but just looking
at this since 8 A.M this morning um it
looked to me like they were advertising
that they do business customers and they
want to hold deposits for businesses
which is what our banks do currently but
they don't have FDIC insurance and
there's been um a you may be familiar
with recent bank failures where they
were most of their customers were
businesses um and when they failed it
was really important that they had FDIC
insurance that was really critical now
if you're talking about a bank that's
truly doing custody or money or money
transmission I think that if it goes
custodia way and they can get a Fed um
payment account you could potentially
have a non-depository Trust Company
doing that at work and holding those
funds in custody and perhaps be able to
access the FED payment system so I don't
think that's a barrier um under current
law like I don't I don't think you need
this if that's your goal okay and so I I
believe custodia is uh licensed in New
Hampshire to do business to do money I
don't know we'd have to look into that I
don't they if they're chartered in
Wyoming that I don't know how that
reciprocity would work we do they have a
money transmitter license to so they
have
them oh they'd be exempt because they'd
be a state bank we would need to look
into that a little bit let me confer
with my folks so however it works out we
we don't want to have a like a a homec
court disadvantage where I don't think
you would based on what I'm hearing you
say all right um I don't think you need
this to do what you're suggesting all
right thank you but it could bear a
little more looking at okay and I'm just
a little confused if I could ask a
question so so why would they need FDI I
see maybe they're holding Securities not
just general deposits I don't I don't
know all the details a very
preliminarily looked at their website
this morning and it did say deposits but
I'm not I haven't had a lot of time to
dig into it if they're holding deposits
that would make them like a bank and
those deposits would be on their books
not like a custody account that the
custody accounts are not on their books
distinction
okay
so all
right what do you want to do with these
bills I mean I to me is I mean
everything here is is all very
interesting intriguing but I'm not sure
any of them are are really ready to to
uh be passed whether we should just keep
them as interim study and keep working
on these things you know so they'd be
ready for legislation for next year but
in terms of the your the cryptocurrency
digital ass said do you feel differently
about that one so 1444 I know we haven't
really talked about the amendment yet I
have more focused I think that's more uh
ready for prime time and the and the
sandbox the self custody one talking
about yeah okay but you know it's a it's
a work session so that's what we're
right okay so um so let's talk let's go
back to 1444 now that we have copies of
it so
um we get past I I have a feel like I
have a pile in front of me who needs a
want just speak to it for yeah briefly
so the the meat of the bill is on first
page line 26 the right to self- custody
and it says the state of New Hampshire
shall not prohibit restrict or otherwise
impair the ability of an individual or
business from doing two things accepting
digital assets as pay for the purchase
of legal goods or services or using
prevent them from using self- custody
digital assets by use of a self-hosted
wallet Hardware wallet or by any other
means that allow the individuals to
retain individual control over the digal
assets that's really the gist of the
bill the rest is uh
definitions
yeah that's how we how many copies do we
make yeah I have did did we make did
yeah yeah the banking
Department yeah I know I I I we're we're
bouncing back and forth between these
that
crypto so it could be a stable coin
that's backed by dollars that would be a
digital asset but it could be is
that uh that's a really big question
that no one's really answered yet so
there they won't answer that
listing now I don't know if that has to
Nita thanks um represent I have a
question for you so does this no longer
relate to digital mining at
all yeah this would be a full
replacement we totally ditch that
because it's not really happening in our
state because our energy costs are so
high like that's one thing we learned
with the governor's commission is they
go to Texas they go to places where so
this is a completely new bill a
different subject yeah well related but
okay yeah separate but
equal yeah my first reaction was that we
might have to have a non-ring Amendment
hearing on this but I guess what what
I'm focusing on just that section you're
talking about is that that this is this
felt like a barn door because you're
there's nobody right now that has
there's no statute now so did your
commission talk about this bill at all
did they ever have we talked about self-
custody that that it was important to
that the state recognize it and this
this is what accomplished that
accomplish I can't I can't present this
as a recommendation from the commission
but that's a section of the report that
right to to reaffirm confirm that it is
okay to to have this in and then you if
you can find a willing party to
negotiate something you could use this
yeah it just recognizes that it's
private property basically okay uh a
question yes um and thisy representative
am does this is this sort of a separate
bill that maybe would have come out of
the sandbox and we look at this bill and
just can the sandbox
Bill uh that applies to the different
bill yeah we're going we went back a
bill so we're going back and forth
between bills yeah this is a this goes
back to the crypto commission okay the
original bill was uh 1444 the original
bill was about local ordinances against
mining of digital assets and since
that's not really happening like that
would be super profil but there is self-
custody happening in our state and this
would recognize it a question okay so
represent spear this thank you uh
so uh this this self uh custody have we
got incidences where people are are not
being allowed to uh maintain custody or
being allowed that that you could have a
transaction like the one I described
where I want to buy a house and and I
have agreement on both sides to use
Bitcoin uh that somebody's preventing
them from doing
that yes so really no no no I didn't say
yes I was saying yeah really um so you
voluntary transactions are legal in New
Hampshire people are buying houses for
Bitcoin um the realtor that sold me my
house specializes in that actually um
and I did not buy my house with Bitcoin
um this would this has to do with uh
have holding digital assets that you're
recognized as that the state won't
interfere with your owning the digital
assets what would that interference that
this has actually been a problem okay
but could you even say what that might
look like this is this is prophylactic
this is this is closing the barn door
before the horse got out so you can't
describe a situation where this could
happen that we yeah we're just we're
just making sure that no no no one ever
said you can't you can't do that okay
because I couldn't picture what it would
look like okay right is that correct
recognizing ownership it's recognizing
that the ownership exists right right
that that it that you could so okay so
that that would be not prop that would
be saying is that yes which you but it
is what you think it
is and you're okay to think that I have
question I know I know uh that the uh
the crypto industry and and its
supporters do not like the idea of a
national the the Federal currency what
is it no what is it called it's a f
digital because of the fact that you're
concerned about seeing them they can go
right into the digital currency and
check digal what's going on digital
assets
so we're g to we're going to make that
legal here in the state of New
Hampshire but the federal government
can't do
it uh I mean I don't understand your
question trying yeah I don't understand
the answer so
uh so but it but it is confusing enough
to me to go with have a red flag go up
okay and say if I can't understand it so
anytime we talking about crypto you your
red flag goes up yes yeah I know a lot
about crypto May sure you do if if if
it's up the subcommittee if the
subcommittee decides of course um maybe
we have a hearing on just this amendment
the the prime sponsor is on board with
this change okay and and maybe we flesh
out the the issues then and uh and then
we decide right like okaying well the
problem yeah the problem is is I was
evidently um thinking that we had all
this time in the world but it turns out
the the speaker is bound and determine
to have a session every Thursday so now
we're going to have to have uh image so
now that leaves and then next Tuesday's
town meeting day which we can't meet so
that means we have next
Wednesday and then we have the following
week we have Tuesday Wednesday and
Thursday every Everything has to be out
of committee so so Wednesday next week
from Wednesday we have to be done with
everything so if we're going to have a
hearing and then try to figure out a
subcommittee um we're we're very tight
on time here I think this should be next
right so have you guys have any
perspective about this bill and like
anything that you could see might be a
problem or not be a
problem so we were talking internally we
want to have our the chief Bank examiner
look at this just to make sure there's
no impact on banks for safety and
sadness my just very like I just saw
this right now so I'm spitballing really
this is a work session please let me
come back and correct the record if I'm
incorrect
um I just want to make sure there's
nothing that forces somebody to take
cryptocurrency like one of our I don't
think it says that but I just want to
Noodle it around in my head a little bit
um so that would be it because we don't
currently regulate like if you want to
take your crypto and go buy something
with it and the person takes the crypto
that's not nobody right that was that's
that was the resolution of our of our
sandbox 201 yes
preliminary so uh one suggestion is to
go back through the crypto report and
search for self- custody and the
discussion around that uh and you know
this is definitely related to those
discussions I can not hear you're saying
I think that things if you if you just a
suggestion if you go back to the
2022 uh commission report there are
sections that talk about self custody I
do remember that yeah so this would be
need to refresh my recollection about it
and I want I was on that committee I sat
in almost every hearing I just want to
just double check
myself right but so the upshot is is if
we're going to have a public hearing on
it we have to have it next week John
this is it is it it would be a non-gain
Amendment it would be a non- gerain
Amendment
right
yeah this is I know you were you because
you this was this B fall in
right all right so
um I guess we should just interim study
these next two B these two
bills you okay with that I think this
one's pretty simple but yeah no it is
simple but just the timing is timing's
Cole uh H
melier
Herbert
Spear and we're missing grassy and
Thaxton
what's do something else
orus
what
question
yeah my mic's not on I'm sorry apologize
uhar spear you mind
idea
okay um all right so the question is uh
interim study U all those in favor raise
your hand one two three four five six
zip
okay all right
um
okay all right who would like to make
it
any discussion on inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
the the motion is
itl oh you think we should pass it
I okay all right all those in favor
raise your hand one two three four five
and those
opposed
five to
1538 and representative macular second
motion okay all those in favor raise
your hand one two three four five those
one
1559 and there's no Amendment for this
bill right we're all good so I move o to
second represent immac thank you I have
a question yes is the banking Department
involved in any of this on 59 this is
their bill their bill it's their bill
this is their bill when you see my name
on it you know it's it's somebody else
is asking me to do
it yeah I know I found out the about
that earlier okay I'm fing okay yep any
discussion on a to
pass all right see none all those in
favor raise your hand one two 3 four
zip
okay last but not
least 1694 relative to establishing a
Bank
I move inexpedient to legislate seconded
melier any discussion on the motion of
any expedience to leg talk forever but
no I'm not going to do
it okay uh motion's clear all those in
favor of itl raise your hand one two
three four five those opposed motion
done
what
steagle